موجز الاخبار من الجزيره اينما كنتم
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله في الذكرى
السنويه هي الاولى لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا قل الرئيس الاوكراني وان النصره
سيكون امرا محققا اذا التزم شركاء بلاده
بوعودهم وعشر رئيس الاوكراني الى ان بلاده
لن تنتصر وحدها ولا يمكن ان تقف دوله
بمفردها ضد مثل هذا العدوان بحسب تعبيره
كما اعلنا عزمه لقاء نظيره الصيني
وقال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني كيف تستعد لشر
هجوم مضاد بالتزامن مع مرور عام على الحرب
من جانبه قلم مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني في
مقابله مع الجزيره ان حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا ستنتهي دون اي تنازلات اوكرانيه
وفي موسكو قال نائبه امينه مجلس الامن
الروسي ان اهداف العمليه العسكريه يجب ان
تحقق بالكامل واضاف ان من الضروري دفع
التهديدات ضد روسيا الى اقصى حدود وان
كانت هذه الحدود هي حدود بولندا بحسب
تعبيره
عقد مجلس الامن الدولي جلسه خاصه على
مستوى اسرائيل
بمناسبه مرور عام على حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا وقال المندوب الروسي لدى مجلس
الامن انهاء اوكرانيا للعمل العدائيه
سيتيح لها فرصه ان تكون دوله طبيعيه وفق
تعبيره
اقرع الاتحاد الاوروبي والحزمه العاشره من
العقوبات على روسيا وكذلك اعلنت الولايات
المتحده وعقوبات جديده عليها تشمل
العقوبات الاوروبيه قيودا على تصدير
التكنولوجيا الدقيقه وقائمه جديده من
الافراد والكيانات ذات العلاقه بالحكومه
الروسيه
قال رئيس الوزراء البولندي ان بلاده سلمت
اوكرانيا 4 دبابات من طرازيلي بارد واضاف
ان هذه هي الدفعه الاولى من اصل اربعه
عشره دبابه سترسلها
قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه ان
بلده طرحات وثيقه للحل السياسي للازمه
الاوكرانيه مشيرا الى ان الوثيقه تتضمن
الوقفه الفوريه لاطلاق النار وضروره
احترام سياده جميع الدول بحسب قوله
ووصف المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم
المتحده الخطه التي قدمتها الصين لمعالجه
الازمه الاوكرانيه بالمساهمه المهمه لجهول
السلام
نقلت صحيفه
جورنال عن مسؤول بريطاني قوله ان قمه
المقبله يجب ان تمنح اوكرانيا مكسبا
سياسيا يحفزها للدخول في مفاوضات ونقلت عن
مسؤولين ان كلا من الرئيس الفرنسي
والمستشعر الالماني ابلغ الرئيس الاوكراني
انه بحاجه لبدء النظر في محادثات سلام مع
روسيا
تتواصلوا في تونس حمله الاعتقالات التي
بداتها السلطات هذا الشهر وشملت سياسيين
معارضين وشخصيات قضائيه واعلاميه ومدنيه
وعربت الامم المتحده وفرنسا عن القلق ازاء
ما يجري في تونس من اعتقالات ودعت الى
الحوار واحترامي الحريات وكان الرئيس
التونسي قد قال انه يعمل على انقاذ الدوله
ولن يتراجع عن ذلك
انتهى الموجز حينما كنتم فبتوقعاتكم بكل
خير